سالنا الناس في الاردن كم من الوقت
تستهلكه على المكالمه الهاتفيه ماذا اجابه
[موسيقى]
ما بتعدوا دقيقه دقيقتين يعني مكالمه
سريعه بس ايام الخطوبه كان الواحد يطول
يعني كان في سبب انه الواحد يطول يسهر مع
خطيبته هيك لا تتجاوز دقيقه تقريبا مع
تطور السوشيال ميديا وسائل الاتصال كله
صارت مسجات بين الواتساب وايميل دقيقتين
لخمس دقائق بس اكثر من هيك لا ما بكثره
بالمكالمه
[موسيقى]
هل من دقيقه لانه ما الي خلق اقعد على
التلفون مو كثير لانه خلص الواحد صار يعني
في برامج تبعون الاتصال اللي على الانترنت
بصير يقضي وقت اكثر عليهم حسب الشخص هلا
في ناس مستعده اضل معهم يوم كامل على
التليفون ما عندي مشكله في اشخاص ما
بتحملهم ثانيتين عباد
[موسيقى]
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات